[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
mit anna zimmermann und christian
sievers
[Musik]
das herz der partei schlägt heute sehr
weit rechts dass der verfassungsschutz
manche landesverbände beobachtet kann
man absolut nachvollziehen teile der afg
stünden nicht auf dem boden der
freiheitlich demokratischen grundordnung
das sagt der parteichef der afg selbst
bzw der der bis heute parteichef war bob
walton wirft hin und er tritt auch
gleich aus der afc aus es ist der
endgültige beweis dass er den machtkampf
verloren hat gegen die radikaleren in
der partei es ist der tag an dem
rechtsextreme der rechtsextreme flügel
feiern wird david gebhard berichtet
eigentlich eine routinesitzung des afg
vorstands bei der es etwa um einen neuen
finanzdirektor und einen neuen kleinbus
gehen soll eigentlich doch minuten
vorher überrumpelt die ankommenden eine
nachricht sie haben nur noch einen
parteichef der andere hat gerade
hingeschmissen ich habe immer versucht
dieser partei maß und mitte zu geben und
hatte den eindruck damit immer weniger
durchzudringen zuletzt gar nicht mehr
und wenn dieser punkt erreicht ist dann
muss man sagen wenn man der partei als
solche keine zukunft gibt und das tue
ich nicht dann ist es zeit zu gehen dass
es jörg merten ein besonderes vergnügen
ist dass er den kompletten vorstand mit
einer ticker meldung kopiert sagt
vielleicht am meisten aus über das
längst vergiftete verhältnis innerhalb
der haft in der vorsitzende traditionell
im bösen gehen bernd lucke 2015 frauke
petry zwei jahre später und immer geht
ein bisschen bürgerliche fassade
schrumpft die zahl der eher gemäßigten
die sich grämen und wächst die zahl der
radikalen die triumphieren ich bedauere
das persönlich sehr es ist seine
persönliche entscheidung die wir zu
respektieren haben
ob die entscheidung so gut war das muss
er wissen weil der letzter zeit in den
letzten jahren nicht ein glückliches
händchen bewiesen aber das war eine gute
entscheidung er war sechs jahre im amt
vier jahre war gut die ersten vier und
die letzten beide hat man sich denken
können in den letzten beiden hatten die
radikalen kräfte in der afg bekämpft die
ihr die jahre davor erst selbst mit groß
gemacht hatte lange hatte man das bad in
der rechtsextremen menge genossen die
anhänger dessen parteiausschluss er
verhindert hatte nannte ihn einen freund
und der freund stand pate beim
verschieben roter linien
[Musik]
ich sehe darin also keine positionen die
außerhalb dessen liegen was was wir
akzeptieren können ich habe dachten wir
wir integrieren die
soweit das möglich ist in diesem versuch
habe ich gemacht und ja das war ein
irrtum ein irrtum der die partei
veränderte die nun so meuten totalitäre
züge tragen und zumindest in teilen
verfassungsfeindlich sei wollen kallwitz
hecke unter dem schutz von weidl und
kuba die fdp zu einer
nationalsozialistischen partei form
sie wollen jedenfalls eindeutig
nationalistische züge da reinbringen ob
kallwitz da noch eine rolle spielt
werden wir sehen der rechtsextrem
strippenzieher andreas kalbitz auf
betreiben läutens aus der afg geworfen
frohlockt schon ein kleiner schritt
vermeiden ein großer sprung für die ard
nun allein parteichef kubala schließt
kallwitz rückkehr nicht aus und tritt
gegen leuten nach das diesem drohe wegen
einer spendenaffäre die immunität im
europaparlament zu verlieren sei doch
vielleicht eher der grund rechtsruck
vorwürfe quatsch das finde ich wirklich
charakterschwach von jörg nolte das
verurteilen wir in dieser weise auch
eine stimmt natürlich auch nicht was er
dort erzählt also er hat sich im prinzip
von dieser partei mittlerweile die
letzten wochen und monaten immer mehr
entfernt auch von den mitgliedern das
haben alle gespürt und ein stück weit
ist es heute auch ein tag der
erleichterung
erneuten gilt als passionierter
schachspieler in der ard war er zuletzt
schach und matt
guten abend
der sie was ist das heute ein bitterer
tag für sie oder für die afd
ach so würde ich da gar nicht rangehen
das ist für mich ein tag eines abschieds
der tut auch weh da will ich keinen hehl
draus machen das war ein achteinhalb
jahre arbeit es ist für mich aber
zugleich auch ein neuer anfang es ist
beides der rechtsextreme flügel ist
aufgelöst hieß es immer aus der afd das
war dann ja wohl immer ein formales
feigenblatt tatsächlich sehen wir heute
hat der flügel gewonnen blöcke wünscht
ihnen für ihren weiteren lebensweg mehr
zufriedenheit
sehr freundlich von höcker ja aber das
heißt doch dass die ganze zeit dieser
flügel der den auch sie immer als
aufgelöst bezeichnet hatten in
wirklichkeit die fäden zieht in der kfd
st
der flügel der begann institutionelle
strukturen zu entwickeln dagegen haben
wir uns gewendet und dann haben wir
aufgelöst und das geschah auch das heißt
natürlich nicht dass die menschen die
sich dieser gruppierung zugehörig
fühlten auf einmal weg sind die waren
weiterhin da und parteimitglieder und
die arbeiten weiter und ich habe immer
gesagt wir haben in dieser partei im
kern zwei strömungen
eine bürgerlich konservativ
freiheitliche und eine eher national
konservativ in teilen völkische das war
immer der grundkonflikt in dieser partei
und er ist bis zum heutigen tage aber
mit dem heutigen tage zieht sich die
eine strömung in ihrer person nämlich
zurück und sie sagen heute
totalitäre anklänge habe ihre ex partei
sollte heute etwas sektenhafte machen
sie daraus das sehen ja andere
beobachter schon viel länger so als sie
was konkret hat sie denn jetzt zu diesem
schritt bewogen oder vielleicht anders
gefragt wer hat sie dazu bewogen
es waren keine konkreten personen es ist
eine kette von ereignissen
die dann langsam dahin geführt hat dass
ich zu der erkenntnis gelangt bin dass
der weg von maß und mitte der weg von
disziplinierung und professionalisierung
wenig immer angemahnt habe und ich habe
das sehr sehr entschieden getan ich
erinnere an den parteitag in kalkar der
fast tumultartige dann verlief aufgrund
meiner brandrede dass dieser weg
tatsächlich nicht von erfolg gekrönt
sein wird und dass ich mich mit den
vorstellungen welchen weg die parteien
nehmen müsse nicht durch sehr zu wort
aber ich muss da noch mal nachfragen
weil woran konkret machen sie das denn
jetzt alles fest sie sagen ich kenne den
laden von innen das ist ein zitat von
ihnen von heute was können sie denn den
deutschen jetzt heute abend über diese
partei sagen was sie als parteichef
nicht konnten oder nicht sagen wollten
also ich verstehe ihr interesse dass ich
da jetzt ganz viele geschichten erzählt
ich möchte nur nicht unfair sein und
nach treten wissen sie das vermeintliche
sollen nicht ganz viele geschichten
erzählen sondern wir versuchen einfach
herauszufinden was sie zu diesem doch
sehr sehr krassen schritt bewogen hat
heute ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel
ich habe im bundesvorstand im august
letzten jahres massiv dafür geworben ein
parteiausschlussverfahren gegen ein
mitglied durchzuführen
das sich als das freundliche gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnet ich sage
dass da werden grenzen überschritten
diesen völlig undenkbar auch wenn das
vielleicht in einer internen
kommunikation gelaufen ist dahinter
steckt ja eine geisteshaltung und ich
habe dort und das ist seitdem mehrfach
passiert festgestellt dass die
mehrheitlich im bundesvorstand hatte mir
nicht gefolgt ist ich habe mich zu
teilen gefühlt wie ein feldherr dessen
soldaten sich in die büsche schlagen
weil auch andere überlegungen für die
eine rolle spielen und wenn man sich
dann mehrfach nicht durchsetzen kann und
das ist mir so geschehen und es ließen
sich weitere beispiele nennen dann fragt
man sich ob man mit dem kurs für den man
mit herzblut steht ob man mit diesem
kurs noch erfolgreich sein kann und da
habe gemerkt ich bin es nicht und ich
habe gesehen dass ich den weg ab einem
bestimmten punkt nicht mehr mitgehen
kann ich bin sehr beharrlich im
verfolgen meiner ziele und ich werfe die
flinte nicht gleich ins korn sondern ich
versuche so lange es irgend möglich ist
und ich sage es ist ein punkt gekommen
an dem es nicht möglich ist und daraus
sich die konsequenz und drehte von
meinen ämtern zurück und aus der partei
aus weil sie einen weg nimmt den ich
nicht zu gehen bereit gehen das heißt in
der afg nach ihnen würden sie das so
sagen kann man sich jetzt als
freundliches gesicht des
nationalsozialismus bezeichnen darüber
müssen die befinden die da sind ich bin
nicht mehr da ich habe dazu eine klare
position gehabt wie zu anderen dingen
auch
es hat keine mehrheit dafür im
bundesvorstand gegeben dann ging es an
alleine landesschiedsgericht
in diesem landesschiedsgericht die
senioren ämter sperre braucht man
vielleicht auch nicht eine abmahnung tut
das und das ist genau die
verweichlichung von positionen die ich
nicht mitzugehen was sagt denn dass über
ihre partei bis heute ihre partei
das heißt dass eine abgrenzung die mir
zwingend notwendig erscheint nicht in
der notwendigen härte und schärfe
vorgenommen wird der verfassungsschutz
will ja die afg beobachten wegen
rechtsextremistischer bestrebungen sie
sind ja jetzt quasi der beste kronzeuge
dafür oder also ich erfülle ich mich
nicht ich bin auch kein innenpolitiker
ich bin kein jurist ich nehme politische
wertungen vor und meine politische
wertung ist dass die partei einen kurs
mit dem ich nicht einverstanden bin und
den ich auch nicht mitzugehen bereit und
ich will eine konservative politik eine
reaktionäre ich will eine freiheitliche
keine beliebige ich will eine
patriotische aber keine nationalistische
politik das sind die positionen die ich
habe und es geht eindeutig in die andere
richtung und daraus ziehe ich die für
mich logische konsequenz dass man ihn in
partei nicht mehr sein kann muss jeder
einzelne für sich selbst entscheiden sie
haben jetzt mehrfach gesagt das sind
ihre positionen aber wenn man mal ein
bisschen zurück kommt und so weit muss
man da gar nicht zurück gucken wollten
das ist von erstaunlicher sinneswandel
den sie da letztlich durchgemacht haben
sie haben noch 2020 in interviews gesagt
die haltungen des rechtsextremen flügels
die seien legitim sie haben davor gesagt
der flügel ist selbstverständlich ein
integraler bestandteil der partei also
man muss sagen wenn es ihnen taktisch
half da haben sie da durchaus paktiert
muss man mit dem heutigen tag eigentlich
sagen sie basteln im grunde genommen
einfach nur an legende für ihre person
nein das ist eine erzählung die sehr
gerne bemüht wird die so aber nicht
stimmt sondern ich habe mich immer da wo
ich es erkannt habe
gegensteuern gegen entwicklungen gewandt
die ich für indiskutabel das habe ich
schon im jahr 2016 gemacht als ich
gesagt habe ich setze mich nicht mit
einem antisemiten in eine fraktion und
ich habe alles dafür getan dass dieser
mensch dann nicht in der partei bleibt
das ist den deutschen parteien recht
nicht einfach das hat vier jahre
gebraucht gerade auch zutaten vor 2020
vorgelesen wo sie sagten die haltungen
des flügels und legitim
ich bin auch durchaus der meinung dass
man in einer freiheitlichen demokratien
breites meinungsspektrum tolerieren muss
deswegen muss ich mir diese meinung
nicht zu eigen machen das habe ich nie
gemacht auch als ich noch davor mal auf
treffen von denen war habe ich immer
gesagt das sind positionen die nicht
meine eigenen sind ich habe in einem
punkt geht und das gestehe ich frank und
frei ein ich habe das für weit weniger
dominant gehalten ich habe gedacht wir
machen eine integrativen kurs und wir
versuchen es zusammen zu führen zu einer
gesamten konservativen partei man kann
nicht hingehen und kann sagen ich
akzeptiere nur meine position ich habe
nie einen hehl daraus gemacht dass die
positionen die etwa einen grünen haken
vertritt ganz und gar nicht meine
position sind okay wenn man zu einer
größeren partei werden will dann
versucht man zu integrieren diese
integrationskurs ist gescheitert weil
die versucht haben und das nicht ganz
erfolglos
nicht der flügel zu sein sondern wie man
jemand ganz gross gesagt hat der ganze
vogel das geht nicht am morgen ganz kurz
noch wo sehen sie die afg in den
kommenden monaten ich
habe mir zwei fragen gestellten vor
dieser entscheidung die eine ist wie
wird der weg dieser partei sein in
zukunft und der andere kann ich das mit
gehen und sie fragen jetzt nach der
ersten frage ich glaube dass die afg
eine entwicklung nimmt die keinen
weiteren politischen erfolg in diesem
land verheißt weil sie sich einfach in
eine richtung bewegt die diesen erfolg
nicht hergibt und ich muss ihnen sagen
aufgrund meiner eigenen position das
halte ich dann auch für richtig wir
haben bis heute afg chef herzlichen dank
für das gespräch ich danke ihnen in
sivas
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen so kurz vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet interessant zu sehen was
der verbleibende afg chef dazu sagt
nachher im heute-journal update hat mir
fragen an timo grub allah
der woche und habeck das sind die beiden
grünen nahmen die allen sofort einfallen
ricarda lang und omid nouripour das
sollen die beiden neuen werden die
spitze der grünen steht vor einem
wechsel der burg habeck lang nouripour
damit ist das künftige spannungsfeld
auch schon markiert das für die grünen
ein altbekanntes ist und ein dilemma
regierungshandeln versus forderungen aus
der partei oder wie viel grün bleibt in
der ampel vom parteitag in berlin
berichtet benjamin chudnofsky
dann wenn ich jetzt wo wenn nicht hier
wiegen wenn ohne liebe wer wenn nicht
wir danke annalena
claudia roth hält die laudatio und
annalena baerbock geht der abschied nach
vier jahren parteivorsitz standing
ovations mit musik die neue
außenministerin sichtlich bewegt ihr
kennt das ja schon passiert immer
anfangen zu weinen
die abschiedsrede von der partei spürt
zu halten annalena baerbock und robert
habeck gemeinsam die bilanz erwartet
positiv ich bin richtig froh in einem
land zu leben wo es eben nicht das
prinzip gibt ein winner takes it all und
die anderen müssen dann ein paar jahre
lang schweigen sondern wo wir die kraft
haben wo wir den mut haben gesellschaft
zusammen zu bringen auch mal einen
schritt selber zurückzutreten das dürfte
für die menschen für die umwelt für das
klima rauszuholen das ist unsere aufgabe
und wer das nicht sieht und wer das
glaubt durch abstrakte debatten abwehren
zu können der verkennt was die aufgabe
von politischen parteien müssen die
grünen in regierungsverantwortung und
wie so oft bedeutet regieren auch so
manches ende eigener utopien die grüne
wirklichkeit gestalten wollen sie aber
wie geht das
die ehemalige friedenspartei steht heute
neben dem nato-generalsekretär
versucht welt krisen zu lösen ich habe
das auch nicht mehr nicht gehalten dass
das ist europa das auf europäischem
boden panzerminen sich bedrohung das hat
also mit den grünen gar nichts zu tun
wir müssen als land als europäische
wertegemeinschaft alle kräfte bündeln
das zu deeskalieren und es ist schwer
genug
die wirtschaft ist in der korona krise
im bundestag spricht der
wirtschaftsminister heute vor dem
hintergrund von 0,7 prozent wachstum
ausgegangen im letzten quartal und stark
steigenden energiepreisen ein grünes
dilemma
wenn wir neue energie partnerschaften
aufbauen also mit anderen ländern neue
handelsabkommen schließen und die unser
land reicher machen und klimaneutraler
machen und diese länder stabil halten
oder stabiler machen dann ist dem
weltfrieden auch gedient und die moral
ist nach der zumindest fragwürdigen
annahme von corona zuschüssen des grünen
vorstand des zumindest angeknackst das
ende der grünen unschuld
naja also wenn das unschuld verlieren
ist
dann weiß ich muss ihnen ehrlich sagen
ich finde richtig das wird jetzt alles
juristisch geprüft werden und dann wird
man sehen dass er niemanden unschuld
verloren hat sondern dass das was
ausgezahlt worden ist zurückgegeben
worden ist
ricarda lang und omid nouripour werden
ab morgen wohl die geschicke der partei
als neue vorsitzende leiten heute ging
bei den grünen eine ära zu ende
zukunft ungewiss
sämtliche nachrichten aus russland und
der ukraine beobachten wir alle derzeit
ja ganz genau wie hanna hat das auch
heute im blick und da gab es durchaus
widersprüchliche signale am mittag hat
der russische präsident putin mit seinem
französischen amtskollegen makro
telefoniert dabei sollen sie sich laut
leg kreisen einig über die notwendigkeit
einer deeskalation der lage gewesen sein
die laterale gespräche zwischen den
staatschefs sollten demnach fortgeführt
werden allerdings wiederholte putin
zugleich die forderung nach
verbindlichen
sicherheitsgarantien ähnlich äußerte
sich der russische außenminister lavrov
bei einem telefonat mit
bundesaußenministerium berbalk am abend
dann die meldungen dass russland ein
einreiseverbot gegen mehrere
eu-vertreter verhängt hat das
außenministerium in moskau erklärte dass
es sich um eine reaktion auf eine so
wörtlich absurde politik einseitiger
restriktionen handele
thema im bundestag war heute der einsatz
der bundeswehr im irak mit großer
mehrheit stimmten die abgeordneten für
eine verlängerung des mandats um neun
monate bis ende oktober obwohl die
grünen das mandat als opposition bisher
abgelehnt hatten stimmten auch sie nun
für die verlängerung seit 2015 sind
deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten im
irak um dort irakische sicherheitskräfte
zu beraten und die anti es koalition zu
unterstützen
in dresden hat heute der prozess gegen
sechs mutmaßliche juwelen diebe begonnen
vor gut zwei jahren sollen die
tatverdächtigen in das historische grüne
gewölbe eingebrochen sein die
staatsanwaltschaft wirft den angeklagten
im alter von 22 bis 28 jahren schweren
bandendiebstahl und besonders schwere
brandstiftung vor die mutmaßlichen täter
sollen 21 schmuckstücke im gesamtwert
von über 113 millionen euro gestohlen
haben bis heute fehlt von der beute jede
spur
die innenministerien und minister von
bund und ländern wollen entschlossen
gegen gewaltbereite corona demonstranten
vorgehen
extremistische bestrebungen sollen
verstärkt beobachtet werden sagte der
neue vorsitzende der
innenministerkonferenz joachim herrmann
bundesinnenministerium band nancy faeser
beklagte dass rechtsextremisten den
unmut über die korona politik immer
stärker für ihre zwecke missbrauchen
würden
wenn es irgendwo um anpassung geht dann
sollte man aufhorchen wenn der
gasversorger die preise anpasst dann
werden sie dabei eher nicht sparen wenn
die airline den flugplan an passt dann
sollten sie gucken ob ihr urlaub noch
funktioniert jetzt passt das robert koch
institut die deutsche corona strategie
an es bleibt ihm wohl auch wenig anderes
übrig weil allein die offiziellen zahlen
wer sich alles an steckt weg galoppieren
jetzt soll die summe der fallzahlen gar
nicht mehr entscheidend seien die neue
strategie eindämmung konzentriert nur
noch auf die am meisten gefährdeten
bereiche klaus brodbeck mit mehr kleines
rätsel für corona beobachte wird karl
lauterbach gleich den erfolg seiner
eigenen strategie beschwören oder das
publikum bloß sich die nerven zu
verlieren oder ich wird der minister
gleich das virus selbst lese oft und
höre oft die politik hätte die kontrolle
in dieser welle verloren das ist nicht
der fall mit den hohen fallzahlen hatten
wir gerechnet die kontrolle haben wir
nicht verloren ist es aber einfach
schade dass wir diese hohe fahrzeuge
jetzt haben aber schauen sie in andere
länder england beispielsweise genauso
war es da auch da waren zum teil die
instanzen wesentlich höher wir also
kontrollieren die welle unser ziel ist
es durch diese welle durch zu kommen
dass wir dann zurückblicken kann und
sagen in deutschland sind sehr wenige
ältere menschen in dieser schweren
omikron welle noch gestorben
lauterbach lobt die relativ scharfen
maßnahmen die dazu beitragen würden die
rechenmodelle des ihm unterstehenden
robert koch instituts die die planung
ermöglicht hätten und er bekommt
zuspruch von diesem institut die see ist
stürmisch ja
und die sicht ist schlecht aber wir
müssen jetzt wirklich einen kühlen kopf
bewahren den tanker weiter auf kurs
halten und gemeinsam durch diesen strom
fahren wir wissen genau wo wir hinwollen
wir trotzen auch dieser welle auch sie
wird vorbeigehen entscheidend dafür und
zur abwehr weiterer
impfen m kämpfen so schnell wie möglich
das ist die botschaft
wer geimpft ist
am besten dreifach geimpft ist ist in
der regel sehr gut vor schweren
verläufen auch mit omikron geschützt mit
diesem alter neben stoffen mit den
nährstoffen die wir vor zwei jahren
entwickelt haben sinkt das risiko zu
sterben um 99% ich appelliere daher von
dieser stelle nochmal von diesem
sitzplatz noch einmal weg bitte lassen
sie sich boostern sie tun sich den
größten gefallen den sie sich tun können
warten sie nicht auf impfstoffe die noch
in der entwicklung sind wir sollten
nicht vergessen dass co wird keine reine
lungenerkrankung ist seine system
erkrankungen die insbesondere auch die
gefäße betrifft da wird mir immer ein
bisschen zu sehr vergessen weil gerade
diese entzündungsreaktion den däninnen
schichten der gefäße jedes organ mit
einbeziehen kann kritik äußert
lauterbacher lockerungen in mehreren
bundesländern die damit vorgaben des
bundes missachten würden ich halte das
für falsch innerlich sprechen einfach
inhaltlich macht es also aus meiner
sicht also keinen sinn überzeugen weder
die länder mit fakten ob das
funktioniert noch ein rätsel
und mit den enormen auswirkungen die
omikron und die maßnahmen dagegen auf
die deutsche wirtschaft haben macht
jetzt anna weiter die hat nämlich an
schwung verloren 0,7 prozent weniger
beim wirtschaftswachstum im vergangenen
quartal damit hatte man nicht unbedingt
gerechnet frank bethmann an der
frankfurter börse vor allem vor dem
hintergrund dass ist ja auch anders
laufen kann wir haben blick nach
frankreich zeigt ja anders als
deutschland hatte frankreich die korona
maßnahmen zuletzt nur leicht verschärft
mit dem ergebnis dass die franzosen das
stärkste wirtschaftswachstum seit mehr
als einem halben jahrhundert hingelegt
haben deutschland hingegen kämpft jetzt
sogar wieder mit einer rezession
zumindest mit einer technischen von der
gesprochen wird wenn die
wirtschaftskraft in zwei quartalen
hintereinander sinkt dass das so kommen
könnte also dass deutschland auch in
diesem ersten quartal sprecher startet
halten fachleute nicht für
ausgeschlossen
sind ja schon jetzt ein problem und das
könnte sich mit blick auf micron sogar
noch ausweiten was es da zu erwarten
wer zuletzt schien ist ja so als
normalisierten sich die lieferzeiten
wieder doch es ziehen bereits wieder
dunkle wolken auf der grund chinas regis
vorgehen gegen die pandemie dürfte den
lieferketten erneut stark zusetzen
sieben der zehn größten containerhäfen
befinden sich in der volksrepublik käme
es hier zu stillständen wäre schnell wie
der sand im getriebe des welthandels mit
absehbaren folgen für die deutsche
wirtschaft der dax bereits heute mit
bremsspuren verliert über 200 punkte
wochenverlauf sind es sogar fast 300
insgesamt also keine woche zum zunge
schnalzen
vielen dank nach frankfurt
nach 23 jahren verlässt sportdirektor
max eberl den bundesligisten borussia
mönchengladbach mit sofortiger sakko und
erklärt dies mit seiner gesundheit das
ist ein ganz simpler grund warum ich
nicht mehr arbeiten kann weil ich
einfach erschöpft bin weil ich einfach
müde bin weil ich keine kraft mehr habe
diesen job sowie dieser job ist benötigt
dieser fein ist benötigt auszuüben
er prägte die mannschaften von borussia
mönchengladbach jahrelang durch seine
transferpolitik sein abgang trifft den
verein inmitten einer sportlichen krise
der spanische tennisprofi rafael nadal
steht im finale der australian open und
trifft im endspiel auf den russen daniel
mit wtf damit könnte nadal am sonntag
geschichte schreiben ihm fehlt nur noch
ein sieg zum 21 titel und damit zum
grand slam rekord im halbfinale hatte er
gegen den italiener wäre teenie gewonnen
mit pdf bezwang den griechen
australien will das vom klimawandel
bedrohte great barrier reef besser
schützen dafür will die regierung in den
kommenden neun jahren zusätzlich 630
millionen euro ausgeben so sollen etwa
mit hilfe neuer technologien
umweltbedrohungen vermindert werden
erstreckt sich über 2300 kilometer und
hat in den letzten 30 jahren mehr als
die hälfte seiner korallen verloren
hoffen wir dass das jetzt hilft das war
der freitag bei uns hier wir beide sagen
danke dass sie dabei waren und wir
wünschen ihnen einen schönen abend so
und jetzt hat matthias vorne auf ein
spannendes zdf polit warum
guten abend willkommen zum
politbarometer eine schonfrist gab es
nicht für kanzler scholz und die
ampelkoalition die korona krise und der
ukraine konflikt verlangten sofort
führungsstärke
anfangs war die zustimmung zur arbeit
der regierung groß jetzt gerade mal
sieben wochen nach amtsantritt muss vor
allem die kanzlerpartei spd federn
lassen wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl
wäre müsste die spd mit deutlichen
verlusten rechnen und käme auf 24
prozent minus 3 cdu csu dagegen könnten
leicht zulegen 23 prozent plus 1 auch
die grünen besser 18 prozent plus 2 die
fdp bleibt im abwärtstrend 10 prozent
minus 1 auch die afg 10 prozent
unverändert die linke 7 prozent plus 1
die unzufriedenheit bekommt vor allem
kanzler olaf scholz zu spüren in unserer
liste der wichtigsten politikerinnen und
politiker die wie immer die befragten im
politbarometer selbst bestimmen verliert
er am stärksten an zustimmung
auf der skala von plus 5 bis minus 5
bewertet nach sympathie und leistung ist
sahra wagenknecht schlusslicht minus 0,1
unverändert davor friedrich merz 0,0
markus söder 0,3 beide deutlich
schlechter platz sieben für annalena
baerbock 0,4 sie verbessert sich stark
christian lindner 0,6 auf platz 5 robert
habeck 1,1 beide mit verlusten wieder
dabei cem özdemir 1,1 auf dem dritten
platz olaf scholz 1,4 mit den größten
verlusten auf platz zwei wieder dabei
karl lauterbach 1,4 und immer noch auf
platz eins angela merkel 2,4 leichte
verluste
das hin und her um eine mögliche
impfpflicht sorgt offenbar für
enttäuschung die ankündigung spätestens
anfang märz soll sie in kraft sein lässt
sich nicht mehr halten
diese woche hat der bundestag über das
thema debattiert ein gesetzentwurf der
regierung liegt nicht vor nur
verschiedene gruppenanträge eine
impfpflicht für alle ab 18
150 impfpflicht und die generelle
ablehnung die mehrheit der befragten im
politbarometer ist nach wie vor dafür
62 prozent wollen eine allgemeine
impfpflicht
36 prozent sind dagegen
gleichzeitig glauben nur 39 prozent dass
sie auch wirklich kommen wird 59 prozent
bezweifeln das
fast auf den tag genau vor zwei jahren
wurde der erste corona fall in
deutschland bestätigt mittlerweile sind
wir in der vierten welle und omikron
bricht immer neue rekorde mit bis zu
200.000 neuinfektionen täglich dabei
erwartet der gesundheitsminister den
scheitel der welle erst für mitte
februar
während sich in den krankenhäusern die
normal stationen mit corona patienten
füllen bleibt die lage in den
intensivstationen bis jetzt stabil
knapp drei viertel der befragten glauben
dass die krankenhäuser den erwarteten
starken anstieg der korona infektionen
bewältigen können 23 prozent befürchten
das gegenteil
eine infektion mit der omicron variante
scheint milder zu verlaufen wohl auch
deshalb sehen weniger befragte derzeit
ihre eigene gesundheit als gefährdet an
auch der anteil der befragten die finden
die aktuellen corona maßnahmen müssten
strenger ausfallen sinkt
gleichzeitig aber glauben nur 21 prozent
dass die pandemie nach der mikrowelle
überwunden sein wird die große mehrheit
von 75 prozent denkt das nicht
neben der korona krise ist der ukraine
konflikt die zweite große
bewährungsprobe für die ampel regierung
der massive aufmarsch russischer truppen
an der grenze zur ukraine wirkt
jedenfalls bedrohlich doch wird russland
tatsächlich ins nachbarland
einmarschiert und einen krieg
provozieren
gut ein drittel der befragten erwartet
dass 57 prozent sagen nein
jeder fünfte findet dass deutschland der
ukraine waffen liefern sollte die große
mehrheit von 73 prozent lehnt das ab
die spannungen zwischen russland und dem
westen verschärfen auch die gefahr dass
die russischen gaslieferungen nach
deutschland ins stocken kommen könnten
der winter ist noch lange nicht vorbei
die gasspeicher im land sind
ungewöhnlich leer die internationale
energieagentur macht russland dafür
verantwortlich gazprom könne deutlich
mehr gas durch die bestehenden pipelines
leiten
55 prozent sind überzeugt dass russland
trotz der ukraine krise zuverlässig gas
liefern wird 39 prozent fürchten dass es
nicht so sein wird
die mehrheit also vertraut auf moskau
als zuverlässigen lieferanten und darauf
dass wir warm durch den winter kommen
hoffentlich erweist sich das nicht als
wunschdenken
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer im zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auf zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer punkt
zdf.de
vielen dank für ihr interesse
das nächste politbarometer gibt es dann
am 11 februar nach dem wetter geht's
hier weiter mit der heute-show ihnen
noch einen entspannten abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
ein stammte und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter eine ausgewachsene sturm lage
erwartet uns an diesem wochenende dieses
sturmtief hier erreicht uns und dann
dreht der wind auf nord bis nordwest und
dann wird es sehr windig vor allem an
den küsten teilweise orkanböen
orkanartige böen in mecklenburg
vorpommern auch möglich und auch in den
bergen wird es orkanböen geben wir
schauen auf die nacht und da wird es
viele wolken geben oder es regnet im
süden ist es teilweise trocken nach
südosten hin gibt es einige
schneeflocken es wird glatt auf den
straßen dort minus 2 bis minus fünf grad
sechs grad plus ganz im westen
deutschlands und morgen gibt es viel
regen im norden und etwas schnee in den
östlichen mittelgebirgen und der wind
legt dann am nachmittag zu sturm und
schwere sturmböen sind dabei und in der
nacht auf sonntag verschärft sich die
lage dann müssen wir auch mit orkanböen
an den küsten in den bergen und sogar
orkanartigen böen im osten deutschlands
durchaus dann möglich temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von drei grad an
den alpen und 12 grad im westen
deutschlands ziemlich mit für die
jahreszeit ja und am sonntagvormittag
geht es weiter teilweise noch mit sturm
und schweren sturmböen vereinzelt sind
auch ganz früh noch orkanartige böen
möglich
drei bis neun grad die höchstwerte ab
montag dann ziemlich durchwachsenes
wetter mit regen und schnee und ein
wenig kühler und damit ein schöner abend